did you just standing there between the
trees good or bad I'm right by the mule
where are you in relation to the burning
car what we do here is unorthodox we
teach the art and the science of
leadership incoming incoming both eyes
are open now we're gonna go my name is
Christian I'm a former marine name on an
undisclosed military base we conduct
multi-day pseudo military operations
with corporate executives and veterans
so that when we conclude these missions
the executives say hey we need to hire a
lot more of these men and women we're
going to help organizations move better
by doing something that's also
considered a social good
right now there's over 250,000 service
members that transition out of the
service every year my goal is to make
sure that no veteran goes through the
same situations that I had to go through
Casey went from the pinnacle of
athleticism to someone who was carted
out of a dusty battlefield in
Afghanistan paralyzed when he was
recovering he was told he was never
gonna walk again he said well no and he
persisted after two years he actually
walked out of the hospital he was
discharged it's the number of months
later in Casey this war hero finds
himself living out of his car for a
while I had just gotten how I was one of
those typical veterans I think you know
what I've got this I'm gonna go out
there I had all these marketable skills
everybody's going to want to hire me I
was wrong when our veterans transition
out of the military they have to find
the uniform that they're going to wear
in their future career my closet used to
be all camouflage uniforms now I'm
talking about pocket squares and ties
and cufflinks but the thing is I love
when I put on a suit it makes me feel
empowered it gives me a sense of
belonging with my peers now I knew that
I can get from where I was in the
military I just needed the opportunity
Christian saw that within me you know
this is the our last night together and
that you've learned a lot really more
than anything you learn about people and
you learn about relationships and how
important that is what always comes my
mind it's how I live a charmed life I
mean you do your stories just it just
cuts the bone
what you guys are doing for these
veterans on a daily basis
you guys are Myers we are going to
change the way that America looks at
hiring veterans hiring a veteran a good
business life is simply better if we're
in service of something bigger than
ourselves what we do here is our
attempted bent the universe we're unsure
what the world dental universe but we're
going to swing like hell at it
[Music]